كيف تعمل فرق الانقاذ في حالات الطوارئ
والكوارث الطبيعيه سؤال ربما يتبادر الى
اذهان الكثيرين ونحن نتساءل ايضا سنكون
اليوم في برفقه احد فرق الانقاذ
اذا وصلنا الى الموقع الذي ستعمل فيه فرق
الانقاذ هناك منهم من دخل بالفعل قائد
الفريق الان يعطي توجيهاته
للافراد الذين سيشاركون
في البحث في هذا المكان
سندخل المرحله الاولى هذه الاليه الثقيله
ستفتح الطريق امام فريق الانقاذ ليبدا
العمل وطبعا الجميع هنا يعمل بتوجيهات
وبامراض قائد الفريق
هو من يحرك الاليات الثقيله ويشير اليهم
ما هي الطريق التي يحتاجها الفريق وايضا
يقوم بتقسيم الفريق لا يدخل كامل الفريق
مره واحده يتم تقسيمه الى مجموعات
[موسيقى]
يوجه الان الفريق للصمت التام
اذا انتهت فتره الصمت
لم يستطيعوا سماع اي
صوت صادر من تحت الانقاض
يتقدم قائد الفريق
مع عدد من المنقذين طبعا نحن نتحرك معهم
ولكن ببطء وبموافقتهم طبعا يحاولون تحديد
مكان
بثغره يمكن احداثها
لارسال معدات للاستكشاف كاميرا في مرحله
من المراحل وان تمكنوا من احداث ثغره اوسع
قد يرسلون اشخاص من الفريق الى الداخل
هناك سؤال مهم نتوجه به لقائد الفريق متى
تفقدون الامل
نتمسك دوما بالامل تمكننا من انتشال ناجين
بعد مرور اربعه ايام على الزلزال ننطلق
دائما من افتراض ان جميع منهم تحت الانقاض
لا يزالون على قيد الحياه
صعبه
هنا بها وجميع المشاعر التي تعتريهم وهم
يعملون على مواقع كهذه هم يتعاملون مع بشر
وهم بشر لديهم احاسيس ولديهم مشاعر ولكن
يضعون مسؤولياتهم في الدرجه الاولى هكذا
ابلغونا خلال مرافقتنا لهم في هذا اليوم
سلام خضر الجزيره مالاتيا جنوب تركيا